on a beaucoup de chance d'être ici sur
le lieu est incroyable fiche de paie
aujourd'hui albert de martha va venir
regarder les petits pendant quelques
jours keystone super bien en super
feeling et nous valent et profiter un
peu au soleil ça fait vraiment longtemps
pour le dentifrice g soit version trop
grande ou sur version trop petite vous
voulez vous voir à quoi ressemble ma
trousse de toilette et voilà ma petite
valise est prête
n'oublie pas que je devrais à nantes le
13 mars à partir de rigoles [ __ ] note
sur 20 tout de suite
pourquoi parce qu l'important c'est pas
très bien je te quitte
[Musique]
retour ce que j'aime bien martèle
instant elle m'a dit plein de photos la
fenêtre de l'avion et regardez ce qu'il
avait hâte d'être en fait qu'on espère
parking donc c'est vraiment pire photo
la pire idée qui se trouve auprès des
joueurs en pleine période du coronavirus
vous prendre la température
je vais vous montrer 100 mètres de
course pour voir ce n'est pas en fait
malade
alors ça c'est impressionnant parce
qu'il ya les renforts tout le monde
portent des masques comme ça de
protection évidemment à voilà tout le
monde a peur du cours d'un virus et tout
et j'ai jamais vu autant de gens dans
leurs yeux comme ça publique porter des
masques et ça c'est vraiment vraiment un
film de science fiction qu'on dirait le
film contagion mais on y colle au ça
veut dire petit est en fait en musique
jeux parce qu'on le savait ce point
culturel le vocabulaire et italiens mais
de porter viano et cendo l'action du
nord est bon et jaurès et tout le monde
s'en fout depuis raconte ici à milan 3-1
dans le match et nous y mettre invité
par jean charles
jacques lamarque et benetton et voilà
qu'on préfère les voir de près un
appartement de la mode
clairement il est par contre unitaire
curieux on arrive à rassembler un petit
peu une façon unique et surtout ici à
milan vraiment
rita lee des phillies pas sur un skate
parc en fête
leurs couleurs de la marque attention
3,73
c'est très moyen
ils nous défient les commandes en
quelques minutes les viols
[Musique]
quinze jours d'agonie suggère la durée
et là la durée la mairie est en fait
[Musique]
bien plaisir autocollants
poser ses lunettes en fait bon ben voila
je vais accepter quoi et qui déjà milan
nouvel avion nouvelle destination
romagné parce que c'est pas mignon ça
regarde le même et il m'a emmené en
synchronisé là comme d'autres
c'est super chaud non cette femme
n'aurait jamais
charisme et de 0,7
les jours
aucun butin sans souci mais les
premières secondes derrière de l'avion
pour voir si vraiment sans achat leur
excellente s'intégrer olala la chaleur
on paye mi mollet peu à peu c'est à la
fois humides et secs
un beau c'est bon on va c'est clairement
une écriture à khalid qui comprend ici
on hôtel incroyable film d'action
directe entrée
le truc est une cathédrale aulas non
mais ça fait 100 mètres de hauteur bon
bah on vient d'arriver à l'hôtel miss
catastrophe a déjà fait une première
économie le téléphone est ici avec ses
partenaires est littéralement viande et
et claquer la gueule contre le sol en
marbre envie on montre le bleu un peu
beau jardin du tout fait simplement son
enfle et ça se voit j'ai un bisou
magique
le bédéiste revanche le loup la caméra
mais clairement je donne de fait j'ai
fait un cheat milla tout à l'heure dans
un restaurant somptueux petite corde à
linge spécial viande au klm
désormais j'ai envie de manger la terre
entière ya les mac ou valve est en train
de re de revenir pourquoi chaque fois
que je veux rappeler étrangers
cela dit comme un bon vieux touristes
hollandais mon corps est vraiment passé
pour passer inaperçu donc tout le monde
voit sans gros touriste de merde or le
petit déj de rêve [ __ ] à la maison
c'est un vieux café et un biscuit la
bretagne roumanie
ces mots et des chameaux là-bas au loin
on va aller voir les chameaux mon pote
déjà c'est pas des chameaux c'est des
dromadaires lui tout peut tu lui tous
les trois ans le petit pote ya pas de m
dromadaire avec eux il n'y a pas de
tuteur légal de dromadaires ils sont la
normale quoi bon la vidéo je pourrais
dire qu'elle est chaude dans les
normales vaut un petit peu point de bron
d'un coup de thibaut petit veau c'est
mon nouveau coach de support officiel
allez voir à ma dernière vidéo pour
mieux comprendre donc là je vais à la
salle de sport un petit bout tu as su
trouver les mots pour me motiver donc
chose promise chose due regarde je suis
à la salle de sport mon pote et je suis
pas là pour enfiler des perles maman
j'ai un petit buffet on est trop quotas
moi qui ai dame âgée mois en fait à la
base on est venu on sortait d'un régime
tous les deux on a perdu tous les deux
près de 7 kilos alors que notre régime
il y en avait vraiment envie dans une
poubelle a tué la déchetterie bien très
gentil monsieur a voulu prendre une
photo de nous est un des noms il a
insisté on accepter regardez à quelle
distance on est de l'iphone c'est assez
culte c'est génial c'est le tueur fut à
sarah d'or alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas le sultanat doman petit
cours de rattrapage foetus connaît en
fait nous sentir trois jours parce que
c'est pas du tout avant le sultanat
d'oman reste une sorte de deux royaumes
qui s'appelle un sultanat quoi donc
c'est un oui mais qu'insultant quoi
situer entre l'arabie saoudite et le
yémen
on est à 5 heures à peu près de dubaï en
voiture donc voilà capital de dôme hans
et ses 9,4
donc allez petit pote petit shooting en
fait on est en train de prendre des
photos et tee shirt on a conçu pour la
tournée mon spectacle sur collector
l'édition limitée quoi et on ne profite
du cadre en tête de mât de faire des
petites photos qui très souvent la star
on met les petits
à l'agréable à martin visiter le souk
e
des fuites et c'est là
du coup
j'ai fait de ma vie
bien ça c'est le bateau du sultan voilà
ces bateaux
on est ici au coeur des souks regardez
moi ces épices cette ambiance et une
ambiance en fait avant tout le nombre
d'objets cas ici c'est un truc de ouf on
est dans des boutiques au coeur des
choses en fait nos millions de petits
objets comme ça à la fois des trucs
touristique il ya aussi et 10 objets de
brocante un peu vieux un peu on peut
employer le mot chine et france
conquérante à la machine pour trouver un
chat si les lampe d'aladin évidemment
moi il me prendre un petit point 17 ans
à symbole en fait d'un hymne un peuple à
assassin's creed du voyage et tu peux
pas et là bas et faire un beau jour ce
serait pour ouvrir un livret assis au
pied est retiré
euro la monnaie locale c'est petit quizz
le rial
proxim hâtivement 3 euros bon on était
obligé 1
on est dans un maul c'est-à-dire un
énorme centre commercial c'est assez
typique ici en a plein en fait nous on
est hyper consumériste ultra capitaliste
c'est une passion de ce second degré on
dirait un penchant pour l'instant voit
comme prévu c'est à ces géants ainsi
père aspects objectifs de notre shopping
là
denis d'âge elle vend le truc très mal
mais en effet justin bieber internet aux
plaies et ouais c'est bien ouais et
alors qu'un problème
alors comme on influenceurs second degré
un pension vous pas prendre sur planète
on rigole avec ça on est très attiré par
ce genre de choses regardez-moi ça on
dirait un endroit a fait spécialement
pour attirer influenceurs ans le petit
train train qui passe le mec n'est fire
du trip uniquement en tout cas j'ai fait
ma connerie je suis allée acheter mes
lunettes à aux clés comme geste indycar
bascule très influençable j'ai eu un
achat compulsif
alors j'ai commandé ceci l'affiché
teaser de dirt 2 dragon et google apps
dedans
cedar détour c'est la croûte sans goût
en fait un drôle de lire c'est bizarre
mais bon ça marrant donc là on va le
faire l'escaladent et j'ai une
prémonition en fait c'est que martin ait
science sait pas encore quelles raisons
si c'est pour un ongle cassé si c'est un
mal de ventre tout d'un coup en fait si
tu veux à la base escalade ses bas ses
deux passions tous les matins je
recherche le grand frisson je me
réveille et voilà quoi je suis très
simple à naître pour aller chercher la
montagne à grimper là clairement ce
qu'on va faire c'est une perf
donc ce matin on devait faire activité
et qu'elle attend nos pensées qui brille
et tout est en fait au dernier moment je
me suis dégonflé
ok les amis on est en pleine session
escalade
on m'a dit c'est ta niveau un bas niveau
tout de suite on a 1 milliards de km
dans le vide en fait face au max mais
bon après moi je suis d'abord
dgo
en fait tu te réveilles le matin et là
tu vas venir le paysage ou plus
somptueux de toute la planète
bon allez pas mal le mec là il part en
randonnée comme s'ils allaient bosser au
top le matin que la tenue casual on est
parti pour trois heures de trek autour
d'eux
les petits villages et tous pour
découvrir un petit peu c'est exactement
comme randonnée mais c'est plus il tient
au fait que sa mémoire retraités et
finalement après cinq minutes de fake
parce que moi j'étais très jeune femme
de dos à la base
[Musique]
beaubelique ici on est à deviner
d'altitude forcément il ya moins
d'oxygène
ça c'est plus dur
[Musique]
ouais
oui
non si on devait résumer ces voyages
qu'est ce que tu dirais tu arrives
c'était des vagues
excellent avec une personne excellente
je parle de ma femme est très
enrichissant on a plein de trucs
et sinon c'est quoi les arabes en fait
sans force important pour ça c'est une
plaisanterie au second degré coupez